With all the talk of the
deficits that we're entering,
and the stimulus bill, and all
the money that's being spent
on the bank bailouts, and
potentially the auto bailouts,
the question that everyone's
asking: Is this going to lead
to inflation?
And that is what I hope to
address in this video.
And I guess a good starting
point is,
well, what is inflation?
It's a general increase in the
prices of goods and services.
So they actually measure it
by-- they take a basket of
goods and services and they see
how those prices compare
to a reference year.
And if those prices go up by 3%,
they might use a consumer
price index.
They'll say inflation
increased by 3%.
So that's what's inflation.
And the opposite of inflation,
if things actually get
cheaper, is deflation.
If one year 10 megabytes of RAM
costs x dollars, and then
the next year, it costs a little
bit less, it's actually
a deflationary process, at
least in that market.
So without the those definitions
out of the way,
let's talk a little bit
about what causes it.
A couple of days ago, I made
these videos on cupcake
economics, where I talked about
what happens when the
cupcake factories have high
utilization or low
utilization.
What might happen with prices?
And the reason why I did that
is because I really want to
make it very clear that it
really is utilization of
factories or of people
that drive prices.
Let's say this is all the
capacity that I have. When I
talk about capacity in this
video, I'm speaking in very
general terms. It's all of the
goods and services that we
could produce.
We could just talk about labor
capacity, and then
unemployment rate is a measure
of what is essentially not
being utilized.
But this is just our capacity,
our productive capacity.
And in those cupcake economics
videos, I showed that if the
demand is pushing up against
capacity-- let me do demand in
a different color.
If demand is really close
to capacity-- and I know
everything I draw kind of looks
like balance sheets, but
this isn't intended to
be a balance sheet.
This is intended just to show
you that demand is pushing up
against capacity.
So in this situation, let's
say, this is capacity.
If demand is at 90% of capacity,
then the people with
the capacity might say, gee,
instead of trying to just try
to sell that extra unit-- this
is demand-- instead of just
trying to sell that extra unit
and have to worry about all
the raw materials and have to
work for that extra unit, why
don't I just raise
prices, right?
So high utilization of capacity,
it leads to prices
increasing.
And this isn't some kind of
fancy macroeconomic principal;
it's true if you're running
a lemonade stand.
If all of a sudden, you're
starting to sell 95% of your
lemonade, you'll probably say,
hey, maybe it's worth it if I
raise the price.
On the other hand, low
utilization-- let me pick
another color --will lead
the prices dropping.
And you go back to your lemonade
stand, and you say,
wow, if I'm only selling 20% of
the lemonade that I make,
maybe my problem is that my
lemonade's too expensive.
And frankly, if there was a
bunch of lemonade stands,
everyone is trying to
sell their capacity.
So just to compete
with each other,
they'll all lower prices.
Actually, I'll throw another
thing in here that's a little
unrelated to inflation, but high
utilization makes prices
go up and it also makes
people want to add
more capacity, right?
So also investment goes up.
Both of those things do add more
capacity, but we won't
worry about that right now.
So if you accept that-- and
I think it's a reasonable
argument, because it's really
based on common sense things
--then I think you'll buy the
argument that, if you have
very low utilization, it's
difficult to have inflation.
And, likewise, if you have very
high utilization, it's
hard to avoid inflation.
And to kind of hit the point
home, actually, I took our
company's Bloomberg terminal
and copied and pasted these
charts here.
And the orange-- and I know you
can't see it that well on
YouTube , so I'll try to make
it clear in my drawing, I'll
do it the same color, --this
orange shows capacity
utilization, and the starting
date right here, I
think it was 1967.
This is 1969, actually December
31, 1969, so this is
1970, beginning of 1970, this
is beginning of 1980,
beginning of 1990,
this is 2000.
This orange line represents
capacity utilization.
So up here this is 90%
utilization and then down here
this is 70% utilization.
So if we look here, in the late
60's, we have very high
utilization.
Arguably because of the Vietnam
War, we had factories
running at capacity to build
bombs and Agent Orange and God
knows what else.
And then utilization
went down.
We could talk a lot about the
history, but, in general, the
interesting thing-- well,
actually, before I go into
what happened, let's think about
what this white line is.
So the orange line
is utilization.
Up here we had like
90% utilization.
Very recently, this was like
2007, we had 80%, and very
recently, utilization has
dropped off, which essentially
just means we're not running
our factories at full tilt.
This white line is
year-over-year inflation
growth, and let me
do that in white.
This is year-over-year
inflation growth.
Actually, let me draw a zero
line, so you can separate
inflation from deflation.
Let me see, zero inflation
is right over here.
That's zero inflation.
And you see, in the time series
that I've done, we've
never had zero inflation,
although we have had periods
of a very high inflation.
But the interesting thing, just
falling into the cupcake
economics and this whole
notion of capacity
utilization, is that
inflationary periods are
always preceded, at least all
the data I have, by increases
in capacity utilization.
So you could view this as the
beginning of a pretty
significant uptick
in prices, right?
And notice, it was preceded
by an uptick in capacity
utilization.
So, if you saw right here, wow,
capacity utilization is
starting to go up-- and
actually, another interesting
thing is to see what threshold
of utilization starts to
trigger inflation.
So over here, you say, OK, when
inflation really started
turning around, we were at
a capacity utilization of
roughly 83%, 84% right there.
And then, if you look at the
next period where inflation
really started to hit-- you can
either pick that point or
that point --where was
capacity utilization?
It was around that same level
that was right there.
It was above 80.
This was about 82%.
And we could pick every
period before that.
Well, since then, inflation
really hasn't
been a major problem.
These are our two major bouts
of inflation, in the early
70's and in the early 80's,
and those were when we had
extremely high capacity
utilization.
So the point I want to make here
is capacity utilization
really is the driver
of inflation.
You actually could find it
the other way around.
So this white line here, you
don't see it because the
orange line-- actually, I
realize that I'm showing you
off of the screen.
Let me actually reduce my
window, so I can show you.
So this is more recent, where
we see that capacity
utilization started
falling off.
I think this is in the
summer of 2007.
And you don't see it there
because it's overwritten, but
the inflation line has also
dropped considerably.
It comes down to here.
But notice once again, although
here it's pretty
close, but utilization dropped
off a couple of quarters
before inflation dropped off.
And that's why I always wonder
why the Federal Reserve Board
of Governors, they always talk
about different inflation
indicators and what to do about
interest rates, when you
do have a pretty good indicator,
and that's capacity
utilization.
The next question that everyone
has is, OK fine, Sal.
Capacity utilization
drives inflation.
We can all buy that.
But clearly, what's going on
right now is just a wholesale
printing of money.
And won't the wholesale printing
of money drive demand
to go up, and then we'll
have very high capacity
utilization, and then we'll
have inflation or even
hyper-inflation?
And my argument there is that's
normally the case.
Normally, if you increase the
money supply, if the money
supply goes up, that should
increase demand.
But there's a subtle, and it's
almost a philosophical point,
but it's an important one, to
realize: Money just allows you
to express demand.
Let's say I really, really want
to buy a Rolls Royce, I
just don't have the money.
If someone gave me $200,000 into
my pocket, then I could
express that demand to
buy the Rolls Royce.
On the other hand, let's say,
I have everything I need.
I'm happy with my Honda and my
two-bedroom apartment, and
someone gave me $200,000.
So they've increased, at
least, my money supply.
Will that increase the demand
for the Rolls Royce?
No.
I have money to express the
demand, but I won't do it,
because I don't think
it's necessary.
So you can make that same
analogy in the economy as a
whole, where you can imagine
an island where, let's say,
there's five of us or three of
us, because I don't want to
draw five people.
And between us, we use seashells
as a currency.
And we're very confident.
And maybe I'm the builder, and
this guy's the fisherman, and
she's the farmer.
Let's say in one year I use a
seashell to get some fish.
And then he uses that seashell
to buy some crops.
Then she uses that seashell
to buy a house.
And I use that seashell again
to buy more fish.
You can see that one seashell,
even though my money supply on
that island is one seashell,
it can transact many
times in that year.
So the velocity in this
example is very high.
So you notice that my expression
of demand happens
in these actual transactions.
I'll do a classic money
supply equation soon.
But you could imagine another
reality, where, for some
reason, I stop trusting
this guy.
I've become very cautious, and
I say, well, you know what?
I don't want to give him my
seashell, because I'm not sure
if I'm going to get that
seashell back again to do
something else.
So you can imagine a reality
where the central bank of our
island, all of a sudden, they
find hundreds of seashells.
And they put seashells in
everyone's pockets so we're
all full of seashells.
But all of us have lost so
much confidence in the
economy, or are so unsure over
whether other people are going
to use my goods and services,
that I don't want to use their
goods and services.
So we all just start
hoarding seashells.
So this is a situation where
the money supply could
actually increase pretty
substantially, but since no
one wants to express it through
demand, it's not going
to increase utilization.
And so in the situation that
we're in right now, if you're
wondering about whether you're
going to see inflation or
deflation, my argument is look
at capacity utilization.
People can point to
the money supply.
This is a classic money
supply equation.
The money supply times the
velocity of money-- that's how
often the actual dollars switch
hands --is equal to the
price of the average price of
goods times the total quantity
of goods and services we have.
So most people say, wow, if the
money supply increases,
then won't prices increase?
Well, that would be true if you
assume that velocity and
quantity are constant.
But we're saying that whenever
you have major shocks and
people lose confidence, this
velocity can slow down
considerably, especially when
things like financial
intermediaries start hoarding
money and people start putting
money into their mattresses.
In fact, oftentimes, people
don't even consider things
that aren't being transacted
money.
For example, those commemorative
coins that they
sell on TV.
They're not considered part of
the money supply, because
people don't use
them as money.
Anyway, I'm all out of time.
I'll continue this discussion
in the next video.